[Music]
wouldn't it be cool to see things
through any wall and any door oops sorry
how about seeing through your own skin
or your dog no no no and no of all
superpowers out there this isn't the one
you want to get your hands on this is
what if and here's what would happen if
you had x-ray vision x-rays are light
but they have different wavelengths than
visible light and that makes them
interact with matter differently
basically they can make some materials
partially transparent like human tissue
seeing x-rays wouldn't be anything like
what they show in superhero movies not
even close
besides it would require you to have
another superpower in your possession
here's why there are very few things on
earth that naturally emit enough x-rays
to make themselves visible that means
you'd have to shoot x-rays from your
eyes onto the object you want to see
through but if you were just running
around blasting them in all directions
you wouldn't see any difference when you
pay a visit to your local hospital
emergency room to see if you've got
anything cracked they place you between
a source of x-rays an x-ray machine and
something that can detect the emitted
x-rays see where I'm going here you
can't be a source of x-rays and an x-ray
detector at the same time unless you
moved very fast and got behind whatever
it is you looked at just before the
x-rays hit it although they're not the
kind of light you can see that doesn't
eliminate the fact that x-rays travel at
the speed of light that means in order
to make use of your x-ray blasting eyes
you'd have to move faster than the speed
of light
ah but here's the bummer from what
physics has taught us that's not
possible
nothing can outrun the speed of light
let's not give up just yet a quick
solution to this problem would be to
cooperate with a friend who's been
granted the same x-ray shooting
abilities your friend would blast x-rays
your way and you would detect them and
the other way round
while you were casually shooting x-rays
anyone not wearing a lead outfit in the
nearby vicinity would be exposed to
ionizing radiation that kind of
radiation can damage human DNA causing
DNA mutations and leading to cancer in
later years maybe you should opt for the
ability to detect x-rays and not emit
them but again there aren't too many
natural sources of x-rays on earth if
they were the only thing you were able
to detect you'd be in almost complete
darkness you could look up to the sky to
see a faint glow of space radiation
mostly blocked out by the Earth's
atmosphere
the only things you'd really be able to
see through would all be man-made
you could start hanging out at a
hospital's x-ray Department when that
gets boring you can move on to particle
accelerators like the Large Hadron
Collider in Switzerland but that's about
all the fun you'd have neither our
bodies nor the environment we live in
are suited to this superpower your eyes
can process about ten million colors
within a visible spectrum anything
between ultraviolet light and red light
with over two million working parts our
eyes are the second most complex organ
behind only our brain they generally
outperform x-ray vision so leave the
x-ray vision to Superman and stick with
red capes and make-believe for now at
least until cancer is no longer a
problem for Humanity but that's a story
for another what if
[Music]
you